uh power rankings time i'm trying to
think of a segway but couldn't so let's
just get to the power rankings and let's
unveil what we have this week they're
incomplete
because week 12 isn't over yet
the steelers still at number one you
can't drop if you don't lose you can't
lose if you don't play
so congratulations steelers you're
holding off the chiefs because you're
still undefeated and we'll see if they
hold that
i will adjust these after tonight's game
uh
and uh if the steelers lose they will
not be number one period although i
don't think they'll lose chris you think
there's a chance they will
your first reaction let's just focus on
the top ten as we always do your first
thought when you saw those
well i i mean i got no big issue
that i look at right there i mean the
top four i think is pretty
self-explanatory
i mean maybe you could switch the bills
and the packers
okay i mean if i was gonna be picky
there that i'd probably do that
i'd probably take green bay in that
match up but i mean i understand you
going there
i do then one that's tricky to me is
like the dolphins at nine
i'm just still not sure about that like
i look at the dolphins at nine and i was
surprised
that i don't know that you got him ahead
of the browns right now i just with the
way the dolphins have looked the last
two weeks and i know they won and all
that but the browns are playing pretty
good football and i don't know about
tool or fitz or where the hell that's
going
but i have no major issues with your top
ten other than that i think it's pretty
damn good
yeah i i worry about the dolphins
without tua
and i have a feeling i don't know this
yeah but
i have a feeling that thumb injury is
more than just uh he'll be fine in a
week type of a thing and with brian
fitzpatrick
it's one thing to beat the jets it's
another thing to face a tougher opponent
so
we'll see if they can continue to stay
in the top ten the team that
that just intrigues me the most this
year is the colts
we dropped them four down to number 10
after they lost
not a close game to the titans they lost
convincing they were dominating titans
yeah and i just i don't know where this
team is and i
almost put the browns i should have put
the browns ahead of the colts i should
have
the browns beat the cults and the browns
have a better record what was i thinking
i don't know what's wrong with me that's
where the browns should be number 10.
right right i would have said i i
probably would have made the browns nine
and you could have made the
dolphins 10 and the colts 11. that that
was that's what i said that's when i
first saw it
and i know we're gonna have to talk
about it that was the first thing that
jumped out to me and i know you're kind
of a believer in cleveland
a little bit and everything there and
stuff and scene what they're doing so i
was just surprised from that aspect the
personal aspect
and they played pretty damn good
football lately so i'm with you what
about
what about the titans at seven right i
mean they're coming off two
really impressive wins they seem to got
their crap together here
and they're starting to round into the
team we thought they might be
you know do you did you have any thought
of maybe putting them
in front of the packers and the seahawks
uh and making that move
no because i feel like they're still
just kind of
yeah look the packers and seahawks both
won yeah so i
it's it's tough to start leapfrogging
and yes it was an impressive win
you could say the seahawks i mean they
only won by six but it was a garbage
time touchdown i
i i i guess i want to see the titans
show me a little more consistency and i
think i had trepidation with them for
the same reason i had trepidation with
the browns i want to see what happens
this weekend when those two teams get
together remember last year
when everyone was thinking browns oh
super bowl run here we go and the titans
beat them down it was an upset
although we said for i said for months
either the titans are going to beat a
weak one here it comes here it comes
here it comes
and i assume that titan's going to beat
him again but i don't know
i don't know i mean this is the chance
for the browns to get everyone's
attention and show that they're not
this team that's in that weird formula
of win the games you're supposed to win
lose the games you're supposed to lose
this is the game they're supposed to
lose so
i just i want to see i want to wait and
see what both teams do this weekend
before i make a push up for the titans
or for the browns or a push down for the
browns i didn't want
you know put the browns in the top ten
and then they get they get shellacked
this weekend why the hell were they in
the top ten so
it was enough for me i'm looking at it
now it was enough for me to put them
past
the ravens and the bucks that i didn't
even think
that hey you're this far you may as well
go ahead and jump the colts too and
maybe jump the dolphins yeah yeah i mean
it's okay we'll we'll forgive you
and you know the fact that week 12 is
not over you can just release some new
power rankings tomorrow
and make that adjustment it's no problem
all right if the steelers lose
tonight will they go any farther down
the list than
two would you think about moving them to
a three
behind the chiefs and the saints i mean
is there any way yes
yes absolutely yes because the saints
have won eight in a row yeah the saints
have won
in a row so um just because the steelers
would have
there's just they're the perfect record
you you when you
still have a perfect record this late in
the season you're the number one team in
the nfl like
like i said this isn't troy state going
undefeated and still being behind
a two loss alabama team this is the nfl
this is one well two conferences but
they're of equal
significance right you're undefeated
you're number one but once you lose
all bets are off and you have a one-game
losing streak
and there's a team that's got an
eight-game winning streak so i think
that if they lose
they will fall to number three i don't
think they'll lose
but if they do they'll fall to number
three yeah okay all right
so let's break down you want to go move
on from the top ten
let's let's do this let's we've got our
questions here let's answer some
questions
uh derek rudolph via twitter has this
question buffalo's defense and run game
is steadily improving week after week
what are they doing differently chris on
both sides of the ball to improve yeah
well i think we
health on the defensive side of the ball
has helped them a little bit
you know having more health than the
secondary the defensive line the
linebackers have gotten a little healthy
so i i feel like they're doing more on
the defensive side of the ball
that's what i would say more than
anything where
it's more creative it was very vanilla
early on in the year and i feel like
teams kind of cracked their coat a few
times now
i see them lining up in different
disguises
you know disguising coverages more
movement that way and i think that's
causing some issues for
for some uh offenses and and then you
know
the bills offense itself that's what's
encouraging about last week
you know yeah i expected them to throw
the ball in the chargers they didn't
they won the game with their defense in
their run game for the most part
and then josh allen made a few plays and
managed the game pretty well
other than one stupid interception so
uh they're off i think they realized too
hey we can't just think josh allen's
gonna throw for 380 and four touchdowns
every week and we're gonna win that way
we gotta have a little balance
a little versatility in our attack and
singletary moss they're both healthy at
running back and they seem to have
gotten something going
i don't think it's anything like
dramatically schematically different
on offense other than they've just tried
to put more effort into running the ball
really ever since that chiefs game and
they've gotten a little bit better since
then
ramsey climbed to number five after
beating the buccaneers in prime
time the loss at home to the 49ers
completion of the sweep by san francisco
they fall
down to number eight is jared goff truly
their biggest weakness right now well
um i for my money yes he's one of the
he's
he's up there he is i mean that was that
wasn't good football
i don't know any other way to say it
it's the same old thing we always say
about jared goff
and and not to say we know you can win
football games but
we've seen like nine out of 10 times
that when they can't run and mcvay
screens
and all these mcvay specials don't work
jared goff is below average when it
comes to becoming a drop back
pocket get on my team get on my back
franchise quarterback
i don't know any other way to say it
it's below average nfl throwing of the
football
it's below average movement in the
pocket and extending plays
and it's just average decision making
you know so
that that that game i mean again after
watching that back yesterday
i i can understand why sean mcvay had a
seven paragraph answer about
you know benching jared goff the other
day because his brain
probably broke going like what the hell
is he doing with some of these plays and
some of these things he's doing
uh he's an issue that way but more times
than not mcveigh and the way they play
doesn't put him on that pedestal to
where he has to be that guy
and that's what they just have to
continue to work on him getting a little
bit better and
and mcveigh finding more tricks for his
offense to kind of help him out
i also think the rams are having an
identity crisis with their running game
sean mcvay so badly wants to have the
interchangeable parts running attack
that the 49ers have and i think sean
mcvay and the rams feeling stung
by the todd gurley situation you put so
much effort so much
sure money so much emphasis into todd
gurley being the guy
and then when he's not the guy what
happens your
running game falls apart but they're not
really committing to this shared job
revolving door they just need to make
one guy
their guy the rams have a long history
of great running backs i remember
lawrence mccutchen back in the 70s they
had eric dickerson they had marshall
faulk they had todd gurley i just think
that it feels like he's trying to
force this job-sharing arrangement onto
the running game
when for most teams you just need to
develop one guy
who and and he's got a back up yeah who
knows his role
he knows his role he's going to come in
to give the guy a breather once in a
while or if he gets banged up a little
bit
you're the guy next man up but but this
this
hey we want to develop this diverse
running attack with cam akers and daryl
henderson and malcolm brown
it's not working it's understandable
maybe they'd be better off if they just
channeled it into one guy pick the guy
that's your guy
and build your offense around him
because i feel like they don't have an
identity i feel like their identity
is short passed to robert woods that's
their identity yeah right
i mean it is in a lot of ways short pass
to robert wood
short pass to cooper cup you know speed
sweep to robert woods
oh inside zone you know oh bootleg
that's it's really what it is you broke
it down pretty damn good
and you know mike i understand what
you're saying you know
running backs they need to get in a
rhythm as a runner too and those type of
things and yeah i'm with you and i don't
think their offense sets
up for running back by committee anyways
i i agree with you there
you know one mcvay's offense
it's simple he has a formula in which he
uses that's very simple and he
understands how to use that oh wait
you're stopping this
okay now i go to this all right now
you've adjusted this i can go back to
this and that
but it's simple i mean we've talked
about it it's run it's speed sweep
it's fake the speed sweep fake the run
screen fake the speed sweep fake the run
play action pass
fake the speed sweep make the run
bootleg that's what it is i mean that's
his whole offense
so you don't need running back by
committee when you talk about teams that
do running back by committee right
shanahan um the patriots
the saints a little bit i know it's just
two guys there
but they have roles within certain
running schemes
and that's to me where it's different
mcveigh and that offense
it's the same it's inside outside zone
almost every run play they don't pull
guards they don't do man-to-man run
blocking
shanahan has running backs where he goes
ooh you know
i like raheem mostert on outside zone oh
i like kevin coleman
when the backside guard pulls and now
he's got to re so he has different roles
and how they fit that way and that's why
it works for them
the patriots right hey it's you know
james white when we're in the spread we
might hand them the ball and then we get
into power condensed you know
formation it's harris up the middle uh
that's where it's a little different
and you know i'm with you i think you
should try to ride one in that offense
and just have a guy come in and spell
the guy
from time to time i think kyle shanahan
is so deep into his head that he felt
like he tried to emulate
kyle shanahan and that's just not
working be who you are don't try to be
anyone else just because someone else
happens to be beating you more often
than not
question about the browns and this this
causes me to feel a little bit better
about not putting them any higher than i
did
andy mack ii theoretically i understand
the browns at 11 because of the record
but honestly could they beat the ravens
bucks and cardinals
each of those three teams are behind the
browns he had a hard time
justifying getting the browns to 11. i
never considered
oh wait maybe they should go even higher
and if i had maybe i would have dropped
them a little bit lower i'm really stuck
right now with the browns
because you can't deny eight and three
no there aren't many eight win
teams right now but they've got eight
wins
and this kind of reminds me of the 99
rams when you look back at the rams
schedule that year
they had a lot of easy games and i know
that
rodney harrison would say there are no
easy games in the nfl but there are
degrees of difficulty yeah there is
and sometimes you just get blessed with
a schedule
where check the box check the box check
the box we got eight wins now so i
really don't know where the browns fit
because i don't believe in the browns
when it's time to play one of the better
teams in the nfl because we've seen time
and again they don't just
lose they get blown out yeah by some of
those teams
you're right well i i mean really the
colts game is the only game we look at
and go
oh that was a quality team that they
beat you know
it they're they're a team that's you
know solid defense but nothing special
and it's like a little bit like your
minnesota vikings where the run it's
everything's predicated on the run game
and if that doesn't work right where it
didn't have huge success
in those losses the pass offense and
things is limited it is that's why i was
never a huge fan of the stefanski
offense it's
it's all about that run game and that's
fine and that's worked well
i get that but yeah i think that's the
big question about the cleveland browns
it certainly is and just how good of a
quality of a football team
are they uh i don't know but the way
they've played this year
you know you look at the giants and jets
and you think hey cleveland's better
than them they'll win those two games
and that gives them 10 wins no matter
what they do
with the other three games against the
titans ravens and steelers
so that is the big question the big
question is going to be just like we
talk about with some of these other
run-heavy teams a little bit like the
rams
you know baker mayfield is more talented
than jared goff in my opinion
there's no doubt about that but if they
can't run the football
can baker mayfield and that pass game
schematically beat football teams i
think that's still a question
that we haven't solved yet in this nfl
season
and i'm glad you compared them to the
vikings because mayfield is just like
cousins in the respect
of when the play that's called works
he's fine when the play that's called
falls apart
he's not among that that handful of guys
who can make chicken salad on the fly
yeah it all falls apart
and and mayfield's elusiveness and
athleticism
isn't the same as the quarterbacks who
who can recognize oh crap that's not
gonna work
i better come up with something else
cousins is is
like mayfield in that regard and uh i i
i just it wouldn't it be amazing
if this team gets to the playoffs
and there's a decision made after the
season or after 2021 maybe they become a
perennial playoff team but but they're
bumping their head against the ceiling
because they don't have a quarterback
who can win the game for them when the
running game isn't there
and that they would decide at a time
when they're successful
to get a different quarterback that it's
it's odd to think of that question
as it relates to the browns because
they've been spinning in the mud looking
for quarterbacks all these years because
they've been bad
the idea that the browns are good but
not good enough
and what's holding them back could be
their quarterback and maybe they don't
sign baker mayfield to a second contract
you know one of these days
one of these teams is going to say we're
not giving you
a 30 million a year yeah right just
because
we're the team is good right just
because you're not a bust
we're not giving you that kind of money
it's gonna happen at some point
and i'm sure the eagles wish they had
done it with carson wentz and i'm sure
the rams wish they had done it with
jared goff and our other team's going to
learn from that experience
i don't know mike i think it's coming
though i think you're going to see it
because of
like we talked we've talked about it a
lot lately with all the influx of
quarterbacks coming in the league
all the success we've seen teams have
with these rookie quarterback contracts
all those type of things you know i
don't think it's going to be like hey
move on but i think there could be a
point in time where they just go like
let's just take baker mayfield because
we're talking about and go
you know we're not we're not paying you
32 million we believe the offense
you know runs through the run game we
like you you're good you can be our
starter but here's 24 million or 22
million
and do you want to go out and free
agency and try to start and make a niche
with a new team and do all that
fine go ahead see how it works we kind
of have a good thing going here right
now
and you're an important part of it we
want you here but we're not going to
ruin the team to make you
be here that's where to me we've seen
the rams and the eagles
yeah flirted with that a little bit and
i'll say this too
with baker mayfield to defend him hey
the way they play it's not necessarily
easy for a quarterback all the time
either
you know run run hey it's great when
it's successful but
oh wait coach this series we ran twice
and it's third and eleven
and now i haven't gotten to throw the
ball and you want me to make the biggest
throw of the day right here
and that that's can be hard i'm not
giving up on baker mayfield i'm not
and mike i think he can work he can be a
guy that i think
if the run game doesn't work i think he
has the potential
to be a thrower and still help the team
win and carry the team that way
to me the the offense needs to grow
there in that area too i'm not just
blaming him i think it's a stefanski
drop back past
conversation to go along with that but
either way the browns are winning
football games
and they seem to be getting better and
there's some belief there and and
they're real they're they're a force to
be reckoned with with that run game
that's for sure
i look forward to the day that the team
says to a starting quarterback who
otherwise has not been a bust
we're just not doing it and if you want
to go out on the open market and try to
get more so be it it creates a hell of a
game of chicken though because
the team's got to come up with a plan if
they're not going to keep the guy
and it could be that they fill the spot
before he has a chance to come back and
say i'll take that 24 million a year
instead of 32 or 33 million a year so he
could be coming bucks at number 13.
mikeness18 is it possible this season
for the bucks
to break into the top five again we do
these all the way
until week 17. they've got 12 games in
their 7 and 5.
so going into the last week of the
season the week 17 power rankings the
best they would be is 10 and 5. i don't
think that's gonna get them into the top
five chris
i i would think it's gonna be close
definitely
um uh you know yeah they'd have to
i mean i don't know it's your power
ranking list but they'd probably have to
win impressively right
four games in a row really be dominant
and then you'd probably have to see some
of these other teams in the top five
lose another game or two to even have
that conversation the bill's got some
tough games so they could easily lose
two games and end up be
you know eleven and five or ten and six
if it got worse than that
you know the packers i don't see them
falling off much so there's a chance but
i think it's gonna be more about other
teams not playing to their potential
either
i think the bucks have top five
potential as a football team as we know
but man it's all over the place the last
four weeks of the year and i just don't
know really how to gauge them or what to
think of them right now
yeah and look they have two weeks to
figure their issues out
and for their sake they need to take
full advantage of trying to get everyone
on the same page and maybe it's just not
going to happen maybe you've got a
couple of stubborn guys in bruce erin's
and tom brady
and and may maybe maybe bruce arians
to quote the line that we almost fully
completed yesterday in relation to brady
maybe
the danny glover from lethal weapon line
applies to bruce arians i'm getting too
old for this
bleep and maybe he walks away and says
someone else can be brady's coach
next year patriots at number 16 back in
the top half of the rankings rooster
1712
the pat's at 16 really i'm a patriots
fan and that's too high i mean come on
it's the patriots
they beat the cardinals they've shown
they beat the ravens
yeah it didn't work out against the
texans but but chris they're they're
still hanging around they're hanging
around they're hanging around
and you don't want them in the
postseason if you're the steelers or the
chiefs or one of the other
good teams in the afc yeah that you know
it's it's like you know fans hey there's
no beauty points here
there's no beauty points they've won
what three of the last four
and we're putting themselves in position
to at least tie the game and that one
they lost if not
win it you know so yeah it's not pretty
it's as ugly as it gets
every week it's like watching 1964
football again but i kind of like it i
do
and everybody's got to stop getting over
like hey this record's this so we
should be able to beat these teams it's
a match-up league
and yeah the patriots at 16 i'll say
this
i probably would have had the the 49ers
a spot ahead of them
all right i'll just say that but there's
teams like you've just said
the cardinals there's the patriots i
mean we just saw what happened
and the vikings by the patriots i think
i'm gonna take the patriots
we saw the patriots beat the ravens who
were number 12 on your list
the browns who we just talked about they
play the patriots
i don't know about that that'd be
interesting so
the patriots have beat the dolphins who
were at number nine
you know so this and the bills who were
four they were toe to toe with them
i don't think it's totally crazy where
you have them i don't it's just never
going to look pretty or sexy
and i just think people got to kind of
just come to terms with that reality
hot blog sports on the sit on the 49ers
at 17. if jimmy g and george kittle come
back healthy soon
what do you think the chances are that
the 49ers make it into the playoffs and
it's amazing what one game can do to
change a team's perception
but completing the sweep of the rams oh
here they are at five and six
oh here they are getting guys back oh
wait george kittle may be back jimmy g
may be back i'm telling you and what
what a difference
to to be the one seed one year possibly
the seventh seed the next year
and be as dangerous if not more
dangerous in the playoffs
yeah i mean it it is unbelievable i mean
it's
kyle shanahan his coaching robert salah
on the defensive side of the ball we
talked about it
all the things they've done to their
roster the players they've accumulated
i mean they're a team that i go watch
out i mean if they get in the playoffs
like you said earlier
you don't want to see them come into
town when i would that run game and debo
samuel and ayuk and
some of those defensive lineman and
company they got to play but man they
got a tough strike i mean they got still
tough games on the schedule
you know so yeah i love the their
prospects when jimmy g
and kittle get back they can be really
dangerous we know that
but buffalo arizona seattle
you know those are toss-up games right
now you can't sit here and say oh i feel
good about the 49ers winning them yeah
i mean they're looking like they're
playing better football in the arizona
cardinals right now definitely
but nothing's a lock as far as those
three games and we see washington with
their defense they might be a pain in
the butt for the 49ers as well
what's your gut saying you're going to
think they're going i'm not good or not
i'm i'm looking at i'm looking at my
predictions oh my god they were horrible
before the season uh the the seven teams
to make it to the playoffs in the nfc
49ers seven seed and that's where i had
them too or someone ready
i i have a feeling they're gonna make it
i have a feeling they're getting in
and uh they yeah if you're the packers
if you're the saints
if if you're uh well who care i mean
the crazy thing with any of the nfc west
teams that's really
that's what it comes down to mike i
think that that's when you look at the
standings in the nfc
you know you just sit there and go the
great thing for them
is they like they need the rams in
arizona
and they got arizona on their schedule
one more time and arizona and the rams
haven't even played each other right yet
so they got two games coming up that
could work in their favor there is a
really good chance
they can make it just because of that in
the nfc west so
we'll see but i think they're probably
gonna have to run the table to get it
done
last point on the way out the raiders
who had been at number 14
whoa for four straight weeks they
finally moved raiders fans
you got your wish you complained every
week why aren't
we moving why aren't we moving well you
moved from 14 down
to number 19 after getting blown off the
field by the falcons 43-6 at raider simp
says as raiders fan
i can't even say anything cause like wtf
happened
and we're still trying to figure out wtf
happened
with the las vegas raiders when they
went to atlanta last week and they
better get it together or they're going
to be
on the outside looking in there are
going to be good teams in each
conference
that don't make it to the playoffs and
they'll only have themselves to blame
because for all of those teams that
don't get in they're going to be able to
look back
chris at two or three games that they
lost that they should have won
and this is a this is a to get blown off
the field in the game they should have
won
unbelievable unforgivable and maybe
something that disqualifies the raiders
from even making it to the postseason
yeah i mean you don't see play-off teams
get dominated or beat like that too
often you don't and
that that is concerning uh it really is
you know
but they still got a lot of things you
like about their football team
and if they can kind of put this back
together this is not over yet either
they just
i don't know what to say they got beat
they got physically beat up they got out
coached raheem was all over john
gruden's offense
and and and the raiders made some stupid
mistakes to compound that too
i mean as poorly as they were playing
there they were
late in the second quarter and early
third quarter it was like 13-3
16-3 and you just kept going okay here
they they'll get it going
and then he threw the pick six at 16 to
three while they were in field goal
position
that made it 23-3 that was game over and
it just got worse from there they
they packed it in and that was not a
good look and certainly a little
concerning
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports